I got to tell you,
this is an interesting time we are in.
And I think you're
responding the same way I am,
which is just letting my hair grow.
Your hair has gotten quite long.
It really has. Yes.
It's been seven months or so
since I've had a hair cut.
It's very much off-brand for me.
I know, you're you're
always the clean cut look.
I find myself doing this a lot now.
I'm doing a lot of stuff with my fingers
to move my hair around,
like I'm sort of like a
Charlie's angels you know.
I've been amusing my children with this.
Let's see it.
I do that.
Pretty good.
And then I tell them
about flock of seagulls,
(both laugh)
and they leave the room.
Yeah, no one really
wants to hear about that.
You know we found this picture of you.
I think this is you in high school.
(Andy laughs)
What's the story with this photo?
You looked like you had no idea
that your picture was being taken.
What's going on?
Well, that was junior year of high school.
I took that picture for the yearbook,
but they gave me a chance to retake it,
and I took them up on that.
So that's actually a
rejected yearbook photo
that no one's ever seen before.
You're kidding. This was rejected?
I rejected that one.
But look, my hair is
getting back there now.
Yeah, you're getting back there.
Oh, look guess what.
You can tell now this was
an innocent young man.
And when I look at this guy,
the new Andy Daley,
the current day Andy Daly,
I see a man who's lost his soul.
Yes, clearly.
But I want to see if I can get that smile,
if I can duplicate that smile.
Cause I don't know what that smile
was trying to communicate.
What does that smile say?
Can you get it back?
It's like, "What's up future?"
(man laughs)
"Hey, future,
I'm ready for whatever you got."
(Andy laughs)
Can I show you one of the weirdest parts,
I still have that I still have that tie.
Why do I still have that time?
No. That's sad that you have that tie.
It's what? It's sad.
I mean,
Not sad, impressive.
(Andy laughs)
It's one or the other.
I don't know which one it is.
60/40